By now, you know that Logan is a creative
and critical success.
Because of the movie's relentless pace, it's
easy to miss out on the significance of anyone
who isn't Wolverine, Professor X, or Laura.
Despite the brief appearances of supporting
characters, they all come with a complex comics
history.
Here's a guide to the characters from Logan
with more meaning than you realized.
And of course, if you haven't seen Logan yet,
avert your eyes.
Donald Pierce
In Logan, Donald Pierce is the primary antagonist.
While there are villains who are more powerful
and diabolical, it's the robot-handed Pierce
and his band of Reavers who relentlessly hunt
X-23 and Logan wherever they go.
In Marvel's comic universe, there's much more
to Pierce.
When we first meet him in Uncanny X-Men #132,
he's an exceptionally fancy cyborg member
of the Hellfire Club, who are nothing but
bad news for the X-Men.
He was eventually kicked out of the Hellfire
Club, since he basically joined to kill the
club's mutant leaders, and in Uncanny X-Men
# 251, he reappears with The Reavers, after
souping all of them up with cybernetic enhancements
and literally crucifying Wolverine on a giant
X — because Pierce is nothing if not subtle.
In his comics incarnation, everything about
Pierce is cybernetic except his head, and
he can survive even if everything else has
been destroyed.
All in all, this is much more impressive than
his comparitively simple robo-hand in the
movie.
The Reavers
Those nameless soldiers with robot parts that
follow Donald Pierce, who Wolverine and X-23
repeatedly cut into ribbons, are The Reavers.
As far as Logan goes, those guys were pretty
weak stuff.
Because, like, seriously… they were beaten
up by a little girl.
And that guy literally has a gun for an arm.
In the comics, however, the Reavers each have
distinctive abilities and reasons to hate
Wolverine.
They also have totally badass late-'80s names,
like Skullbuster, Bone Breaker, Lady Deathstrike,
and…
Pretty Boy. Pierce combines these cyborgs
with a few Hellfire mercenaries who'd been
torn apart by Wolverine and repaired with
robot parts, and the Reavers are born.
Before meeting Pierce, some of them used the
teleporting mutant Gateway to commit robberies
all over the world.
They've also tangled with the everyone's favorite
heroic murderer in Punisher #33, but like
their destructible, detachable body parts,
The Reavers always come back new and improved.
They're basically an '80s cyberpunk vision
brought to life, which probably explains why
their look was toned down for Logan.
We had more than enough of that in Mad Max.
Caliban
This guy continues to pop up in unexpected
places.
We last saw him in X-Men: Apocalypse, where
he charges Mystique money to find mutants
and help ferry them to safety.
A very different version pops up again in
Logan as someone who once used his mutant
tracking abilities to help Pierce and others
hunt mutants, but now serves as an assistant
to Charles Xavier and Logan.
While he's given a moving arc in Logan, Caliban's
comic incarnation has a richer backstory.
When we first see Caliban in Uncanny X-Men
#148, he's in the middle of a creepy misadventure
where he uses his super-strength to punch
Spider-Woman through a window and abduct a
teenage Kitty Pryde — mostly because he
just wants a pal.
Later, things get more intense in Uncanny
X-Men #179 when Caliban is tired of being
friendzoned and abducts Kitty and slaps her
in some kind of sewer wedding dress so he
can marry her.
Which is not as romantic as it sounds.
He eventually lets her go when he realizes
that's a really poor dating strategy.
Later, he ends up living with X-Factor.
By issue #24 of their ongoing series, Caliban,
frustrated that his tracking power doesn't
give him real power, asks Apocalypse for a
boost.
He ends up becoming Apocalypse's Horseman
of Death, with increased strength and intelligence
thanks to genetic alterations by Apocalypse
himself.
He eventually divorces Apocalypse and joins
X-Force, but only until Apocalypse brings
him back into the fold as the Horseman of
Pestilence.
Eventually, Caliban returns back to his barely-articulate
self before getting killed in New X-Men #45.
And then, because it's comics, he gets resurrected...and
killed again.
It's a pretty complex arc of power and redemption
that Logan only kind of touches on.
Rictor
Perhaps one of the most surprising faces we
see in Logan is Rictor, the de facto leader
of a group of fellow young mutants who have
also escaped experimentation.
Just like his comic counterpart, he has seismic
powers and shows natural leadership abilities,
but that's all we get to see during his brief
time on screen.
Rictor first appeared in X-Factor #17, where
he's tracked down by none other than Caliban.
After being rescued from a group abusing his
powers, he's welcomed into X-Factor.
He later joins The New Mutants by issue #77,
but leaves to join Weapon PRIME in X-Force
#11, a group whose sole purpose is hunting
down Cable — who Rictor believes killed
his father.
A few issues later, he realizes the error
of his ways and joins X-Force, which is led
by Cable.
The dude is pretty indecisive.
As a member of just about every X-team ever,
Rictor didn't even give up fighting evil when
he lost his powers during the House of M event.
He joined X-Factor Investigations under the
leadership of Jamie Madrox, the Multiple Man.
Who, if you think about it, is probably the
worst person to have as your boss.
X-24
One of the more interesting film throwbacks
in Logan is the appearance of X-24, an imperfect
clone of Logan, that mostly exists so we can
watch Wolverine in a mirror match against
himself.
While X-24 doesn't really exist in the comics,
there are a few Marvel characters that he
may be a riff on.
Spiritually, X-24 seems pretty similar to
Albert, a robotic duplicate of Wolverine that
was built by Donald Pierce in Wolverine #37
in order to kill his mutant nemesis.
Albert eventually gets over his programming
and becomes an ally of Wolverine.
However, the movie makes it clear that X-24
is a clone rather than a robotic duplicate,
which seems to reference more recent comics
centering around X-23's early adventures as
the All-New Wolverine.
At the start of her solo series, she encounters
a few clone versions of herself who are seeking
vengeance on their creators.
They all have different personalities, which
seems to be a major step above the mindless
killing machine briefly portrayed in Logan.
Dr. Rice & Gabriela
Logan doesn't show us much of Dr. Rice, the
man behind the program that's cloning and
training young mutants.
Pierce even credits the guy for causing the
extinction of mutants, which is a pretty big
deal.
His quick death means that we don't get to
see the full depth of his relationship with
the young mutants, but just like the film,
the Dr. Rice of the comics is significant
to X-23… even if he's only in a few issues.
In Marvel's comics, we first glimpse Dr. Zander
Rice as a younger scientist in X-23 #1, carrying
on his father's legacy with the Weapon X program.
Bad science goes down when Dr. Sarah Kinney
is brought into the project, and the only
way to save her work is to have an embryonic
X-23 clone popped into her womb, which she
brings to term.
Which is a whole lot more intense than Nurse
Gabriela's role in Logan.
That's when Dr. Rice takes over, torturing
the young Laura to bring out her mutant abilities,
including extracting her claws by poisoning
her with radiation, and building in a trigger
scent that drives her into a berserker rage
whenever she smells it.
Rice uses a brainwashed Laura as a mercenary
to slaughter dozens of people, including just
about everyone in a fellow scientists' family.
Laura ends up killing Dr. Rice and destroying
the Weapon X facility, but Rice gets his final
revenge.
He manages to slip the trigger scent in Dr.
Kinney's hair, so Laura ends up murdering
the one person who ever loved her.
As she lays dying, we see an envelope full
of information about where X-23 should go:
to visit Logan and Professor X.
Sound familiar?
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!